Boris certainly does pick his moments
with David Cameron out of the country on
holiday he decided to speak out on
Europe and reveal the news that he is in
fact going to be standing as an MP in
the next general election now we don't
actually know where yet but one of the
places that has been mentioned is here
the Oxbridge and south ruislip
constituency with Sir John Randall
stepping down it does leave a seat free
for Boris to step into but what people
who live here really think at the
Uxbridge and district conservative club
news that London's mayor could be
heading their way had everyone talking I
think that's his attitude has got a
pleasant personality and he doesn't
appear to be fri or two to say is mine I
think he's a very nice man he very
rarely says anything to upset power that
and I think he's just he's just nice
although he'd be one of the frontrunners
Boris is by no means a shoo-in and he'll
have to put his name forward just like
everyone else by the start of September
if he does want to be considered to take
over Sir John Randall seat boys very
popular around here not everybody's
taste is a bit Marmite as a politician
but he certainly reached his part of the
electorate that others don't including
myself at this sucks bridge t-shirt
company an unofficial poll has been
taking place printers have come up with
a novel way of working out if the winds
blowing in Boris's direction no he's
winning but only just it was like two to
one we've knows but I think he must have
been sending people in because there's
loads yes
although he's one of the Conservative
Party's most famous faces Boris can
certainly polarize opinions not the
biggest fan of him but I think it will
probably be quite exciting I have quite
a few people talking did more interested
in politics maybe he actually has a
little character and so well known
because of his hair as well a joke but
also backing Boris the prime minister
who tweeted the announcement was great
news regardless of what David Cameron
might privately be thinking he knows he
has to keep Boris on side particularly
because he is such a popular figure
within the Conservative Party whether or
not though that popularity can translate
beyond Greater London if he was to be a
challenger for the leadership of the
party well that's another matter
altogether